the nebia by moan quattro is the world's
most advanced shower head it only uses
50 percent as much water but with a
super high pressure spray click the link
below and use the code pacman for 10
off all nebia products
well if you've not been uh paying
attention to the news for the last um 20
or so hours closer to 24 now uh vladimir
putin's russia has started an invasion
of ukraine and this is
i mean listen you know at a certain
point
when you see 190 000 troops massing at
the border
and you understand that it really is
starting to not make sense merely as a
posturing exercise what putin is doing
you start to consider this might be the
precursor to some kind of an invasion
and almost exactly as predicted by many
vladimir putin creating a pretext for
that invasion using all sorts of fluffy
language like peacekeeping to justify
that invasion
doing it slowly
but a slow invasion is still an invasion
and that's what we have going on stock
markets around the world uh very rattled
in anticipation of what may be very
erratic energy prices further supply
chain delays and all of the economic
sequelae we we will talk about once we
get a sense of what the scope of this is
going to be but for the time being
sort of following the georgia playbook
that's not atlanta georgia where
marjorie taylor green is from i'm
talking about the country of georgia and
um possibly all of this meant to goad
ukraine
into an overreaction to provide an even
bigger pretext for a larger scale
conflict so let's kind of talk through
what is going on
yesterday uh okay so let me back up even
there are
what we might call
separatists in ukraine separatists
meaning
they don't want to be part of ukraine
they want to be part of russia okay
two of the regions in which there are
such separatists are regions and i i'm
going to do my best with the
pronunciation here
the donetsk region
and the luhansk region these are on east
uh eastern ukraine you can pull it up on
google maps and and sort of take a look
at what where these are so what vladimir
putin did early yesterday or actually it
was early in the u.s it was already kind
of in the afternoon in russia and
ukraine is
recognize those uh as um regions as as
uh legitimize legitimately recognize
those areas as independent so putin is
saying okay
it's part of ukraine
uh donetsk is part of ukraine luhansk is
part of ukraine but there are
separatists there who quote really are
russian they speak the language they
want to be part of russia so we're going
to say those are independent regions not
ukrainian regions now if you're ukraine
you say wait hold on
it's it's part of the country it's
ukraine but putin says no those are
those are independent regions
he then hours later after some mild
sanctions were imposed by the eu and the
united states on on putin for doing this
hours later and really the sanctions
were imposed on those regions rather
than on what we might consider russia
proper
putin says hey
are the separatists in those quote
independent areas that i've recognized
they are going they're under attack so
we need to go in and send in
peacekeeping forces into that area it's
the putin playbook hook line and sinker
and there shouldn't really be anything
surprising about it
this is what he was signaling for a long
time this is what various foreign policy
analysts and experts were saying could
could be done for a long time some kind
of pretext to then send in troops but
you know they call them peacekeeping but
it doesn't matter how slow it is it
doesn't matter if you say you're there
to keep the peace it is still
fundamentally an invasion we have video
where you see
um
tanks rolling down the road this was
yesterday shortly after this
announcement was made and of course the
question now is to what degree is this
going to escalate or grow now there are
some people who we'll talk about in a
little bit
who are really going out of their way to
sort of defend and normalize what russia
is doing and you can be against american
involvement and be against war and be
against violence the way that i am
and still recognize that this is a
classic russian playbook that this is an
invasion that russia has no right to
send tanks
where they are sending tanks into the
donetsk and luhansk regions and just
imagine a similar situation with mexico
or quebec these are not perfect
analogies but imagine that mexico said
hey you know what
um there are people in texas and arizona
they look like us
and they speak spanish our language and
they would prefer
to be part of
mexico rather than the united states in
texas or arizona so we are recognizing
these enclaves of mexican-americans as
mexico they are independent as far as
mexico is concerned well in the u.s we
would say yeah but that's the united
states and i mean they could go to
mexico you're not stopping if you want
to welcome them they could go and then
mexico says well listen on the basis of
the independence of these uh separatists
we're going to send some peacekeeping
troops in come on guys nobody would go
for it think of quebec
another analogy these are not perfect
analogies but they they are useful in
thinking about this
in quebec there is a separatist movement
imagine that that separatist movement in
quebec canada said well we don't want to
be our own country
we want to be part of the united states
would would the u.s have any right to
say hey those quebec separatists we
think of them as independent because
they really want to be part of us oh
they need us to help keep them safe
we're going to send some tanks there
give me a break guys it's absolutely
absurd now we have video from the eu
foreign policy chief joseph burrell
who is still kind of hedging a little
bit as to the terms that are being used
let's take a listen
well the russian troops has entered in
donbass
we consider donbass part of ukraine
so certainly the russian troops entered
into the donbas ukrainian
i wouldn't say that a fully fledged
invasion
but russian troops are on the ukrainian
side yeah they've invaded one part of
russia is what we i'm sorry one part of
ukraine
um the idea
maybe just do this and then back off
we don't know and again i hope that
people recognize that all along i've
said
we can make assessments based on the
signals but we don't really know what
putin plans to do this could just be one
tiny step a day so there's never any one
day where it's like wow look at what
happened and then they moved towards
kiev
um
[Music]
it's just it's not completely clear
we are also going to have to consider
what putin's greater ideology here is
and it's sort of like the idea of
pointing back to the former ussr
ukraine is really important in putin's
mind in kind of recreating that and
we'll talk about that on the bonus show
today but also in terms of tactics this
is really kind of back to like an old
war concept which is can you just change
your country's borders by force since
world war ii
and since the codification
in international law that prohibits the
threat or use of force against
territorial integrity or political
independence we've seen few attempts to
just change your country's border by
force in this degree now you could say
well you know there's a bunch of areas
of the border
in india where there are constant
disputes and small skirmishes and little
bits of land taken and given back and it
is changing the border in a way by force
in in major ways there have really only
been four attempts since world war ii
north korea in 1950 trying to conquer
south korea
on north vietnam
successfully conquering south vietnam in
75
indonesia uh annexing more less than 75
and that very short
very short-lived
iraqi annexation of kuwait in 1990
before it was liberated in what we call
the first gulf war so
this is not super common since world war
ii it will be important not only to
watch what happens in russia but also to
watch china's behavior and ambitions on
the basis of what happens with russia
ukraine because if russia gets away with
this
china's interest in similar action with
taiwan may increase so a lot at play
here and in the immediate it's going to
remain extraordinarily chaotic
i want to look at some fox news reaction
to what is taking place in the russia
ukraine border area particularly donetsk
and luhansk where russia has now invaded
slowly but they've they've invaded um
fox news immediately went to blame biden
and it's kind of i mean it's sort of
funny but it's not
i half jokingly tweeted yesterday
afternoon
before the invasion
how long until they say trump never
would have let putin invade ukraine or
are are they already saying it and it
actually happened very quickly but was
hilariously kind of spoiled by fox
news's own reporters here are some
examples hannity spent the vast majority
of his show last night um blaming joe
biden
and saying that this is biden's weakness
is what has allowed this to happen in
russia ukraine etc etc this ignores the
fact that trump was totally
under the thumb of putin seemed enamored
with putin as well as many other
authoritarians during his presidency
this ignores that circumstances have
been building for probably 20 years
that relate to what is maybe even more
that that are now take that relate to
what's taking place on the russia
ukrainian border but despite hannity
spending much of his show blaming joe
biden when reporter jennifer griffin
pops up she goes you know sean actually
what's going on predates this
administration hannity sort of upended
by his own reporters sean how we got to
this point is a long story and it
predates the biden administration it
goes back and includes mistakes made by
every u.s president since the soviet
union fell apart which putin has said
was the worst geopolitical catastrophe
of the 20th century uh oh well that's
not the narrative that sean hannity has
been pushing on his show even peter
ducey uh who some consider one of the
doofiest reporters out there
hannity was complaining oh joe biden
called the lid he's not doing anything
even ducey has to tell hannity actually
even though it's nighttime biden is
actively coordinating a response with
our allies and the reason that we have
not seen him yet is because they're
trying to get everybody on board and
he's been working the phone trying to
get a bunch of allies to sign on to his
statement with him something uh-oh but
but sean hannity said biden's doing
nothing and he called the lid and this
is all his fault this is of course so
much bigger than biden but the response
similarly to when joe biden left
afghanistan the narrative is biden is in
the wrong biden is the cause of problems
biden is the reason we don't have a
solution and the very same people who
were saying
biden's gonna get us into wars and
biden's bad and trump would have been
better because trump kept us out of wars
those very same people are saying well
biden should have been more aggressive
to prevent this from happening so they
are going to go with this narrative no
matter what even a republican senator
ron johnson is doing the old blame biden
this was him last night
but the fact of the matter is there's
not much we can do right now
what we should have done is maintain
strength
you do achieve peaceful strength but
that's not just military strength it's
also economic strength and as i was
saying earlier just about every action
president biden has taken has weakened
america it's emboldened our enemies
they're very optimistic they're very
aggressive when they sense weakness
they're going to act so wait a second
the same peep this is a reminder guys to
think what are our principles and are we
standing by them the same people who
were saying we should be more friendly
with russia we should we should be
friends with putin we should be friends
with russia we we should be nice we
don't want war with russia now we're
saying biden's been too weak he hasn't
shown strength he hasn't deterred these
people should not even be part of the
conversation they are just horrible
people and they don't care about
anything other than criticizing
democrats there it's not they they add
nothing to the conversation
we're going to take a quick break and
we'll be back with more coverage of
what's happening in russia and ukraine
one of our sponsors is nebia who's
introducing their newest shower head the
nebia by moan cuatro it was designed by
former nasa engineers who spent years
researching how to save water quattro is
the world's best high pressure water
saving showerhead starting at just
dollars and quattro uses 40 to 50
percent less water than traditional
shower heads helping the planet helping
your wallet still giving you the high
pressure water stream you love with four
different spray modes literally takes
one to two minutes to install easy as
screwing in a light bulb i love it i
have the rain shower version i've been
using nebia shower heads for a while now
i love saving the water and i love the
high pressure spray it's really the best
of both worlds nebia the maker of
quattro also offers sustainable bathroom
accessories i have the soft gray bath
mat and the nebia double shelf the
quattro showerhead is just 119 but nebia
is giving you 10 off when you go to
nebia.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is underneath this video the david
pakman show is a viewer and listener
supported independent media program a
little later today in the context of
upcoming cpac actually we're going to
talk about what the right gets right
on funding independent media and
activism that the left lacks but just
remember
it's a good idea to fund some shows that
you like it doesn't have to be this one
but i would love it if you signed up at
joinpakman.com
lots of great member benefits you can
read about on our website
joinpakman.com
so this is just absolutely fascinating
you may remember this democratic
congresswoman former democratic
congresswoman named tulsi gabbard
who
really um
had a faction of the left like 2 2
basically um two percent of the left was
absolutely enamored with her and she
would use terms like regime change and
endless wars
in order to
sort of um convince people i guess that
she was like maybe on the left but the
truth was much of what she said was
always reactionary and since leaving
congress after her completely failed
presidential bid
uh she's really become a darling of the
right appearing regularly on fox news
she's going to be speaking at cpac which
we'll get to a little bit later
and this is almost beyond parody tulsi
appeared last night with sean hannity
and her take on the russia ukraine
situation was so outrageous
so unhinged so unabashedly pro-russia
that propagandist sean hannity had to
pump the brakes and say hey hold on a
second
putin has had these territorial
ambitions for a very long time here it's
not
just about security tulsi appearing and
saying oh what putin's doing is that
he's protecting russia
what he's doing is for their security
and hannity has to be like listen
putin's had these these territorial
ambitions for a long time and says
ukraine's not even a country um when
hannity makes more sense than tulsi you
know she's nuts take a look at this
ending the world that we live in and not
the world that maybe some people wished
existed and that reality is putin has
made very clear all along
that uh their security and his mind uh
is what's at stake here and they do not
want to
interrupt nato putin also said ukraine
is not a country
and he has been saying this going back
many many years so this has been these
territorial ambitions have existed
security component
they they have they go way back and they
they pre-exist this i love what he says
i want to focus on the security
component right because that's the
component that's that's interesting to
you
she is so unhinged that hannity has to
say hey tulsi that there's kind of like
other realities here that you're not
living in
and i'm gonna try to pull you back
towards them like hannity's saying
your pro-russian propaganda is a bit too
much
this is when a friend would be like
tulsi you might want to sit this one out
when hannity has to slow you down
and of course it is is once again a
reminder of all the people that got
bamboozled by by gabbard into thinking
she's uh she's some kind of uh she's
speaking truth to power or she's she's
on the left she's a true progressive the
last real liberal or whatever and it's
it listen uh hillary clinton's not
likable
and it's very popular to dislike hillary
clinton
but when hillary said
maybe russians are grooming tool c for a
third party run i i don't think hillary
was literally correct but hillary's
instincts about tulsi were completely
right i mean it is
at the end of the day i actually wonder
does tulsi believe this stuff or does
she just want attention is this a
character that she's playing you know we
we've speculated that
candace owens for example
is not really this ignorant right-wing
loon that it's more of a character she's
developed for for profit uh we've
wondered did 40-year-old then
40-year-old dave rubin
really go from being a bernie supporter
to a trump supporter through some kind
of genuine political awakening or was it
because of the money that came attached
with saying i've quit being on the left
i don't know i don't know if tulsi
believes this stuff or or is just saying
it because it's developing this
profitable character for her i don't
even know if it's profitable but what i
can tell you for sure
is that when hannity is slowing down
your pro putin propaganda and you're
supposedly on the left
you've really got to be evaluating um
so sort of like what positions you're
staking out here and unfortunately
there are people who have sort of woken
up to the the scam of tulsi gabbard of
that two percent of the left that fell
for her
maybe one percent you know half of it
has woken up and is like oh my god that
was really really bad and i've seen some
people publicly even apologize for it
but some people are still falling for it
and if you want to see examples of it go
to my twitter dpakman look at my post
about tulsi uh speaking at cpac and then
just read the comments read the comments
and you'll see the degree to which
people are still unhinged here and have
completely fallen for it really going
mask off here and i mean
good job i guess to sean hannity for
shutting it down
now let's go from hannity to another fox
news propagandist tucker carlson how is
he reacting to the russian invasion of
ukraine well he's doing it by siding
with vladimir putin
as vladimir putin quite literally
was invading ukraine yesterday
tucker carlson came out and said hey
ukraine isn't even a democracy it's not
even a democracy implicitly justifying
the russian invasion here is tucker
last night
ukraine is not even a democracy despite
what joe biden endlessly claims ukraine
is a corrupt eastern european autocracy
that has spent millions of dollars
lobbying politicians in washington and
by the way made joe biden's family writ
okay
so
tucker isn't wrong
in the sense that ukraine
is
a corrupt
autocracy but russia is even more of a
corrupt autocracy so justifying the more
corrupt autocracy
invading
the less corrupt autocracy in this way
really doesn't make any sense and you
know let's let's dig into this a little
bit more
whether we call something a democracy
is very binary
the point is there are major issues in
ukraine major issues with the rule of
law
major issues with the administration of
justice in ukraine women's rights are
kind of a disaster in ukraine freedom of
expression hate crimes are out of
control in ukraine the real serious
issues in ukraine
but number one those issues are worse
than russia but that's kind of what
about ism so let's not even focus on
that
it's it's kind of weird
for tucker to justify
russia's invasion of ukraine over things
that russia has a worse record on but in
a sense it's what aboutism
the real issue is tucker implicitly
invalidating ukraine's sovereignty and
saying putin can decide what happens in
ukraine if putin decides
that ukraine
is corrupt
putin can invade that's really the issue
the implied point is that ukraine isn't
even a democracy
so therefore it's okay for putin to
invade everything he says about ukraine
applies to russia 10 times over is
russia a democracy is putin not corrupt
is there freedom of the press in russia
come on come on and the u.s propaganda
machine
sails
full speed ahead and um it it to some
degree i feel like we don't even have
like a real defense
against this type of propaganda um it it
it has pervaded and so many people are
literally rooting for putin and russia
here and against joe biden which is
which is a very strange way of showing
how america first you are as they claim
to be um also funny
is that the right wingers
accusing ukraine of not being a
democracy
are the people
who have been accepting trump's efforts
to undermine american democracy i mean
the number of hypocrisies
and contradictions is stunning the very
same people who despite joe biden
winning in 2020
said well
i don't know that he really won and it
would have been fine for pence to
overturn it it would have been fine for
the rioters to prevent the certification
uh to try to give trump another
opportunity it would have been fine for
states to send alternate electors as
arizona and some other states were
thinking of doing as part of the
so-called green bay sweep they have
undermined american democracy at every
opportunity and now are justifying
putin's invasion of ukraine by saying
well ukraine's not really a democracy
come on now think back to the second
iraq war in 2003.
in 2003 when people like me were saying
this war doesn't make any sense
we shouldn't be doing this this is a
terrible idea ukra
iraq didn't even have weapons of mass
destruction the entire intelligence case
made for going into iraq is bogus
these right-wingers were saying you're
rooting against america you're rooting
against our troops you're defending
saddam and they were wrong of course
saddam was a bad guy but things were
relatively stable geopolitically with
his presence in iraq but he didn't have
anything to do with 911 and he didn't
have weapons of mass destruction we
weren't rooting against the u.s we were
saying let's not even get involved in
this those people who said you're
rooting against the us they are
literally defending and supporting putin
now
and we saw clips from from tucker there
are clips from hannity here's one other
bizarre clip from last night's tucker
carlson show where he says
he sent
a letter
to both the russian and ukrainian
presidents as well as to congressman
david cicilline and that sicilini is
repulsive but hopefully he'll agree to
be interviewed like it's it's beyond
parody
so today we sent another letter to
vladimir putin asking for an interview
right we get it
we also sent a message to the president
of ukraine we would like that interview
too okay now neither one of these men
runs a democracy by traditional american
standards both of them are tyrants true
but they're in the news and we would
love to talk to them an interview is
hardly an endorsement
in that same spirit we've also reached
out to congressman cicilline's office
inviting him on this show david
cicilline is a former mafia lawyer who
represents one of our most corrupt
states he is a repulsive man is it
immoral to talk to him no it's not
immoral it would be interesting and so
we hope congressman cicilline accepts
our invitation
i mean it's beyond parody the
congressman is a repulsive man and we
hope that he accepts our invitation to
be interviewed
we've dealt with booking what we might
call hostile or adversarial guests
one of the things we never do
is to say we find you repulsive in
asking for the interview it's i it's
just i know tucker has a whole team of
people over there
i would suggest
not
violently
with rhetoric but not physically
uh attacking the character of the people
that you're trying to interview we'll
have these clips on our instagram if
you're just listening today
find us on instagram at david pakman
show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
this is a super interesting story that
we've actually been covering for several
months there's this guy named neil
cavuto he's a host on fox news fox
business and neil cavuto
had cancer
has multiple sclerosis
and recently got covered for the second
time the second time and he ended up in
the icu
and the interesting thing about neil
cavuto is when he came back from his
first bout with kovid which was much
less serious he kind of admonished
people in his audience for sending him
messages about how they want him to die
and he kind of confronted his own
audience and said go go and get the
vaccine
he now has again come back
and called out his own audience after he
ended up very seriously ill with covid
and he says i was told had i not been
vaccinated i wouldn't even be here i'm
just telling it to you the way it is and
the fact that this guy
constantly has to call out his own
audience for their false beliefs is
really something but good for him for
doing it check out what he had to say
yesterday so i wasn't really hiding
anything i just felt that i wasn't the
story the stories on this show were and
are the story it's about you it's not
about me just like this show my opinions
don't matter you matter the news matters
but this did drag on a long time for me
so you really do deserve an explanation
from me and here goes
i did get coveted again but a far far
more serious strand what doctors call
covered pneumonia it landed me in
intensive care for quite a while and it
really was touch and go some of you
wanted to put me out of my misery darn
near got what you wish for so sorry to
disappoint you but no the vaccine didn't
cause that that grassy knoll theory has
come up a lot
my very compromised immune system did
because i've had cancer and right now i
have multiple sclerosis i'm among the
vulnerable three percenters or so the
population that cannot sustain the full
benefits of a vaccine in other words
it simply doesn't last but let me be
clear doctors say had i not been
vaccinated at all i wouldn't be here it
provided some defense but that is still
better than no defense maybe not great
comfort for some of you and frankly not
great comfort for me either
this was scary how scary i'm talking
ponderosa suddenly out of the prime rib
in the middle of the buffet line scary
that's how scared
no matter i'm not here to debate
vaccinations for you just offer an
explanation for me i owed you that i
didn't want to become the story but for
many of you i did
so now you know the story
time to get back to far more important
matters the the degree i mean listen
if your audience
is so unhinged and weaponized
that this regularly you have to explain
to them
simple realities about vaccination and
covid maybe this isn't the right
audience for you and of course i'm not
like a big defender of neil cavuto i for
the for the most part i find his
political views just kind of uh
um
mildly disgusting in the sense of like
yeah he's he's just kind of like a
center-right primarily economic
right-winger and i don't agree with him
on much but his audience
seems absolutely horrible and of course
we know that they are just think back a
few months ago when he had kova the
first time maybe this was more like uh i
guess this was about six months ago
he shared some of the emails he got from
people wishing him dead
uh we've got a tj who also emails it's
clear you've lost some weight with all
this stuff good for you but i'm not
happy with less of you i want none of
you i want you gone dead kaput finite
get it now take your two bit advice
deep six it and you
that's uh rather harsh neil so
uh but i figured i'd relate that to you
for the sopranos uh prequel yes it does
sound it's not kind of like that okay
now we got vince
uh vince tweets hey guys i bought a new
car after being told it was the best
then i it blew up after i left the car
lot so now i'm begging everyone to
please buy the same car sorry i was just
pretending to be neil cavuto which i
think is uh being a little uh sarcastic
there in that last tweet
you think a little bit a little bit a
little bit a little bit okay a little
bit i know you'll love that here's
another tweet politifact politifact bias
neil cavuto has been fully vaccinated
for months and has been a vocal advocate
about the safety and efficacy of covet
vaccines publicly and repeated
repeatedly on air this is not a new
position for him which is true neil this
is not a new position and that's kind of
what we were stressing you know
seriously said look this is something
from the very beginning i've been saying
that i think the better part of valor is
if you haven't been vaccinated it might
be a good idea for you to get vaccinated
i understand those for religious
personal reasons don't want it but i
understand also the numbers that the
more who do get vaccinated the the
bigger the drop in in cases absolutely
yeah didn't fall on all receptive ears
like this no clearly not i got another
one for you ignis uh aspiring to aspire
tweets cavuto is the tigger of talking
heads ahead okay anyway i think you guys
get it and this has been something he's
been dealing with for a while and this
was his and again we covered this at the
time he's been doing this for a month
and his audience just doesn't seem to
get it here he is begging people think
about someone other than yourself when
it comes to the vaccine we've lost 5
million globally to this we've lost
nearly 800 000 in the us
take the political speaking points and
toss them for now i'm begging you toss
them and think of what's good not only
for yourself but for those around you if
you don't want to do it for yourself if
you think it's a pain in the ass i get
that right but think of others around
you i dare say people who experience
this or see loved ones who've been
affected by this or have never died from
this are not judging the wisdom of
mandates they're wishing they got
vaccinated and they didn't i'm
listen i sometimes have disagreements
with like a sliver of my audience there
are people who disagree with me on my
take on russia ukraine there are people
who disagree with me on my take on
hate crime enhancements or cuba or
venezuela or crypto or you know whatever
whatever
um but if the majority of my audience
seemed to be at odds with the fact that
i think the vaccines
protect you from dying from covid which
is what the science shows
uh i accept rather i accept not i think
or believe
um i would be reconsidering what the
hell i'm doing now my situation's
different because i am my own platform
in the sense that cavuto has taken his
views and he works at fox and he has the
fox audience okay
if he went somewhere else he would have
a different audience presumably i don't
know how many people are super loyal to
kavuto but he seems sort of uninspiring
in that way it's not the same for
someone like me
in the sense that we're on platforms
where you can just watch somebody else
and so i don't think i would end up in a
situation where where such a significant
portion of my audience disagrees with me
about something so fundamental but these
are people where nothing will change
their mind at this point in time and we
know the numbers we know the data we
know everything although i don't agree
with neil cavuto politically
i'm glad he didn't die i'm glad he was
vaccinated and i see no reason to
question what the doctors told him
which is at the level of severity that
you got sick this time in the icu
if you were not fully vaccinated it's
likely that you would have died that
seems reasonable to me
and uh whether this will change
anybody's mind in kavuto's audience i
have absolutely no idea
uh i want to look at um just a kind of a
i don't want to say this is the final
kind of coda on this story but
we're kind of closing the loop on this
classified documents thing that we've
been covering regarding donald trump a
glenn kirschner a legal analyst said on
msnbc
that donald trump is facing a five-year
felony over the classified documents
scandal as you now
may know we've covered it a couple of
times donald trump did indeed take
classified documents to mar-a-lago to
his house those were since recovered by
the national archives and the full
story has been turned over to the
justice department for criminal
investigation here is glenn kirschner
appearing on msnbc talking about the
legal liability here and remember faces
five years is very different than
something will happen but let's listen
you know glenn the judge's ruling says
quote to deny a president immunity from
civil damages is no small step the court
well understands the gravity of its
decision but the alleged facts of this
case are without
precedent your reaction
my reaction is donald trump may be
reaching the end of his rope i agree
with paul that there is i think a
hesitation among prosecutors both state
and federal nobody wants to be the first
one to charge a former president who's
committed any number of crimes i predict
jonathan once the first brave prosecutor
who has the evidence to indict donald
trump brings that indictment everybody's
going to want to be the second
prosecutor
so that's that's interesting first and
foremost because we've been talking
about this
i guess we might say hesitation to kind
of cross the rubicon because there's
this
again it's not a policy it's sort of
just like a
um
uh
an unspoken
agreement i don't even know what to call
it there's this tradition
of not charging american presidents
current or former
but this is a unique circumstance in
that there are so many different reasons
why trump might get charged but yet i
think kirschner is right kirschner is
often hyperbolic he's made predictions
that haven't haven't come true so you
know take that all with a grain of salt
there is some degree to which it makes
sense
that no one prosecutor would want to be
the first to charge a former president
um then let's move on to where he talks
about the five-year felony glenn is
switching topics just a little bit how
can the january 6 committee use the
information
that donald trump took classified
documents to further its investigation
yeah that is a five-year felony the
national archives has reported and
referred to the department of justice
for investigation the fact that donald
trump removed classified national
security information from the white
house and he whisked it away to
mar-a-lago jonathan if that were you or
me or paul you can bet we'd already be
indicted now that part is absolutely
true for a number of the different
things trump has done normal people
so-called would absolutely have been
indicted already but again
faces a five-year felony is very
different than anything is likely to
happen i would love it if the evidence
points to charges and a conviction for
trump i would love for that to happen if
that's what due process determines but i
still do not believe trump will see any
jail or prison time period wake me up
when he actually faces some consequences
he's been dodging all sorts of legal
entanglements for i mean listen
certainly the five six years since he
started running for president but even
longer than that when you consider the
trump organization and at a sort of
basic gut check level think about the
absurdity of trump as president has the
ability to declassify anything he wants
he could have just declassified the
stuff that he wanted to take he doesn't
and instead he just takes it without
declassifying it and now he has stolen
classified documents
the most logical explanation that i've
seen
is the documents are worth more still
classified they're worth more money but
that's a crazy explanation but it's also
the most reasonable explanation in the
sense that what trump did doesn't make
any sense will he face consequences i
doubt it but there are now multiple
criminal and civil investigations
georgia new york justice department
looking at the documents the stuff with
the trump organization and the
misstatement of the values of assets
this this it it's going to be years
and
maybe trump's best bet at getting out
from under all of it
is to run for president in 2024 and win
which is yet another reason why we have
to be prepared for him to try to do that
again
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow alright so now let's get
to that story that i uh alluded to
earlier dozens of you emailing me and
saying david
what is happening tulsi gabbard is
speaking at cpac the conservative
political action conference
what the hell is going on here let's
discuss it this weekend
actually start starting thursday night
and our coverage will start thursday as
well
cpac is happening in florida uh cpac the
conservative political action conference
is a sort of who's who of republicans
right-wing extremists religious
conservatives conspiracy theorists and
all of these other different
aspects of the american right wing
and as a guest
they are having former democratic
congresswoman
former democratic presidential candidate
tulsi gabbard who i thought was on the
left and in fact while she was running
in the democratic primary you had people
who said this is the only true liberal
left this is the only true leftist left
because people fell for it she would say
regime change wars and endless wars and
people would say oh she's so great she's
so fantastic notice that cpac's
promotion of tulsi doesn't even mention
that she was a democratic presidential
candidate it doesn't say that she was a
democratic congresswoman it just says
presidential candidate and people fell
for this stuff i didn't and you all know
that
and some of you did and i told you day
after day
you're being tricked
don't fall for it
don't fall for it the buzzwords she
would use
would make leftist some leftists fawn
all over her
uh she's against wars and stuff so she's
good
and i'd criticize her and i'd be called
the dnc tool
and a dnc plant and part of the
concerted effort to
take away attention from tulsi or
whatever in fact i did quite the
opposite even by just talking about her
most of my audience was like david she's
completely irrelevant to this race why
are you even talking about her and it
was because you know people were
telling me some people were saying david
she's the only real liberal
she has a much better shot of winning
the republican nomination than the
democratic nomination and i am issuing a
call right now
to the people who got bamboozled by her
just stand up and say
i got tricked
i'm gonna do better next time it's okay
just admit it it happens to all of us
but
i also want to include something serious
on this it's not just about
we were obviously right about tulsi it's
not yeah okay
there's a very good tweet that our
friend farron cousins from ring of fire
put out about cpac
and he said quote we're all going to
spend the next week mocking cpac while
ignoring the fact that we don't have the
level of organization or attention we
don't have that level of organization or
attention on the left we're at a
tremendous disadvantage and that rarely
gets mentioned and farron is
exactly right
i've been screaming for a decade they
are better than us at this they are
better than us
the left barely even funds independent
media never mind something like cpac
the right understands you've got to pour
money into on-campus stuff you've got to
pour money into young professionals and
getting them over to your way of
thinking you've got to have events
you've got to have people who feel like
they're part of something
you've got to fund media they fund
turning point usa and all sorts of
different right-wing shows we have
almost none of it on the left and they
love to say oh but george soros is
pouring money into this that the other
thing etcetera etcetera um the left
barely funds this type of stuff in the
right way
and when i talk about hey you know like
only half of one percent of our audience
is our members on our website
i'm not just saying hey it'd be cool if
you supported our work i'm also saying
at a certain point
we've got to fund the things that we
think are important and having a big
infrastructure
of right-wing media and right-wing
activism all coming together is a really
big deal for the right it it just is
there's no way around it
there's this conference netroots nation
i used to go to on the left
and i think it's like the biggest thing
the left has and it's it's not great you
know i have friends who still work over
there it's not great first of all
you know how i often say to you guys
these little toxic elements of the left
are very very small
like it we the the right loves to say oh
the left is all identity politics and
wokesters and all this different stuff
and i explained to you it's actually
really small net roots which was like
the only thing we had
unfortunately over represented some of
those toxic elements of the left i don't
even know if net route still exists i
know they did some online only stuff but
like if that's the best we have and the
right has cpac turning point usa all of
these different uh think tanks and
they're so well funded how can we hope
to compete so yes we are going to
ridicule the things set at cpac i will
be live
uh uh with cpac coverage thursday friday
saturday sunday it's gonna be a huge
weekend of insanity we're gonna laugh at
it it's gonna be funny to some degree
but in the back of it we have to
remember they are so much better
organized than we are
and unless we can get it together
even though the country keeps moving to
the left the electorate keeps moving to
the left if you look at issues
they're going to keep winning they're
going to keep winning and we need to
understand that
marjorie taylor green has appeared on
conspiracy theorist alex jones infowars
and she wants to make it known that she
is not crazy she says it bothers her to
be treated like she's a crazy person
this is all starting to be beyond parody
let's take a listen to marjorie taylor
green and it just bothers me so much
they treat me
as if i'm some kind of crazy person
like i have three horns coming out of my
head but what they don't understand is
they're the ones that are crazy right
everybody else is crazy she's not
everything she does is completely normal
and by the way she says this with an
infowars sign behind her which is a
choice to do that and she seems unable
to realize that alex jones is crazy um
it's very similar to
mike lindell
claiming
to have evidence that
is going to put 300 million people
behind bars
and then saying everybody else is crazy
because they don't realize the evidence
is so obvious at a certain point a
non-crazy person and i get that these
i'm not i'm not literally using these
terms i'm not stigmatizing mental
illness but wacky maybe we use wacky or
disconnected from reality at a certain
point
a person who's connected to reality
would realize when you say you have
evidence to imprison 300 million people
for their role in the 2020 election you
would realize
i'm the wacky one right and it's the
exact same thing with marjorie taylor
green just completely disconnected from
her own reality that she's saying
outrageous things that no serious sane
person could possibly believe she also
is uh continuing to say them even as she
claims to be not crazy
at an event in texas over the weekend
which we talked about earlier earlier in
the week she says you know aoc was a
bartender so she's not smart
okay where is that energy going to be
created
y'all
solar and wind
don't you know
come on aoc so much smarter than all of
us she was a bartender
right
[Applause]
right
you silly conservative republicans you
probably have small businesses and
things like that
shame on you independent people that
know how to balance a checkbook
in all seriousness people can be smart
coming from all walks of life i know
people who have every type of job you
could imagine and they are smart people
okay but is marjorie taylor green's
background really anything to number one
prove her intelligence and number two to
put her in a position to make fun of
other people's work backgrounds like
marjorie taylor green's dad gave her and
her husband
his general contracting company oh okay
wow well so she ran a business well the
atlanta journal constitution
investigated and they determined she has
had no significant presence at the
company whatsoever so she sort of didn't
really run the company her dad gave her
she then started crossfit training
and ended up founding a crossfit gym
and if we all wanted to play the game
that she's playing we could say well
i'm sure marjorie taylor green is smart
i mean she had a crossfit gym right it's
sort of like neither here nor there
but we can only be led to believe that
marjorie taylor green thinks bartenders
aren't intelligent but crossfit people
are bartenders aren't qualified to be
members of congress but crossfit gym
owners
are and in reality what we need are
measures like can you think critically
do your beliefs follow from the evidence
do you have a normal level of empathy
with which you can understand situations
that other people are in and then the
last thing i'll say about this also is
you know they they claim that they are
about
the working people
they are against the so-called elites
now half the time when they mean elites
they just mean jews and it's an
anti-semitic cover like when they say
globalist you know you guys understand
that these are often coded words now but
if you're for the middle class if you're
for the working man and woman
um
then
why
would it be disqualifying
that aoc was a bartender and so of
course their principle that therefore
the little guy
uh falls apart very quickly through
their own elitism that is very clearly
displayed in this way even though
marjorie taylor green has really nothing
in her background that would make her uh
feel like an elite by her own standards
and it's pathetic and it's disgusting
and we should remember their stated
principles are abandoned as soon as they
want to make a point against one of
their political enemies
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219
to david p
a number of you calling in writing in
about this very question this is from
the eggman who asks it
so eloquently
hey dave i have a pretty basic question
is the city of kiev the one that used to
be called kiev yes
shalom yes shalom to the eggman uh
it is so here's
many of you wrote to me because
yesterday during our coverage of the
russian invasion of ukraine i was
talking about kiev
and in the comments as well as an email
voicemail many of you said
sir what the hell are you talking about
isn't it kiev here's the back story the
spell it all stems from the spelling
in english the anglicized spelling for a
very long time the capital city of
ukraine was spelled k-i-e-v
and when you look at that that very
clearly would make most english speakers
say oh it's kiev that makes sense it
spelled k-i-e-v and it's pronounced kiev
a couple years ago a number of media
outlets including npr decided
uh we are going to
change the spelling and the
pronunciation to be more in line with
in ukraine the spelling was changed to k
y i v
and when you see kyv
most english speakers would see that and
they would say oh that looks like kiev
right okay so that's what happened the
idea was we've kind of anglicized it
away from what it actually is
in ukraine
let's try to match up with that more so
now it's it's a new spelling kyv and
it's a new pronunciation kiev spell it
however you want it say it however you
want it and russia has started executing
a slow invasion of ukraine as we covered
earlier in the program so appreciate the
egg man calling in about that
uh and appreciate the opportunity to
clarify on today's bonus show we are
going to talk about the history and the
history is quite extensive
of why russian president vladimir putin
is obsessed with ukraine we will also
talk about why it's ukraine and not
the ukraine
okay saying the ukraine
would be like saying well anyway i'm not
even going to get ahead of myself okay
let's we're going to talk about that on
the bonus show we are also going to talk
about the first public option healthcare
plan in the u.s
which is not getting the traction that
we had hoped we're going to talk about
its details and we're going to talk
about why and then lastly
if you have filed your tax return
and it's taking longer than usual for it
to be processed etc the irs is dealing
with such a backlog and a worker
shortage that they are actively trying
to hire more people to actually go
through that backlog of tax returns and
modifications and resubmissions etc and
we will talk about how long it is all
expected to take that's on today's bonus
show sign up on my website
joinpackman.com you'll get instant
access to the bonus show also a reminder
many live events upcoming in the next
week starting thursday evening
we will be live with cpac from florida
the conservative political action
conference thursday friday saturday
sunday donald trump expected to
keynote cpac i guess on sunday afternoon
and we will be live with all of it
monday i will deliver my state of the
show address
one day before joe biden tuesday night
will deliver his state of the union
address which we will have live on
youtube twitch and facebook so i hope
you will join me for many if not all of
these live events and in the meantime
sign up at joinpacman.com to get access
to the daily bonus show for our members
only i will speak to you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
the nebia by moan quattro is the world's
most advanced shower head it only uses
50 percent as much water but with a
super high pressure spray click the link
below and use the code pacman for 10
off all nebia products